je m'appelle fanny fanny valter vienne
marseille morceaux à marseille une
famille la fille facile quand brad sur
les fesses quand on perd la pure chambre
heureusement bonne mère je n'aime pas
les boules je n'aime pas les pétanqueux
non plus en fait je préfère la
signification étymologique de fanni qui
veut dire femme libre il y a dix ans
libre je n'étais pas j'étais prisonnière
prisonnière des indicateurs de la
performance du chiffre d'affaires de la
croissance prisonnière de ce qu'on
voulait que je fasse mes parents ma
famille mes enseignants mon professeur
de flûte mais entraîneur de sport
j'étais la meilleure à l'école la
meilleure délégué la meilleure grande
soeur est grande et qui montrent
toujours l'exemple à ses trois petits
frères et sa petite soeur la meilleure
sportive la meilleure à la flûte la
meilleure épouse la meilleure maman est
la meilleur ingénieur commercial j'étais
tellement à fond dans cet indicateur de
la performance que tenait même pour
faire mon shopping
j'étais avec le chrono je suis quand
même super fier du score 7 minutes 30
pour mettre l'eau des pâtes à bouillir
décembre de chez moi des cinq étages
rejoindre le magasin le plus proche un
kilomètre 7 repéré un pantalon l'essayer
le payer revenir est remonté à temps
avant que l'eau des pâtes ne déborde
j'avoue j'ai quand même brûlé quelques
casseroles et poêles avant voilà où
j'étais à courir après tout et n'importe
quoi et en fait
au bout d'un moment je me suis pris un
mur le mur de la lassitude le mur de
l'ennui landes m'a sauvé on ne sort
jamais indemne d'une vie en inde
j'avais un visa de travail qui madird
m'interdisait de travailler et alors
j'ai pris le temps j'ai pris le temps de
regarder la vie et de la savourer
comment ces indiens peuvent y être aussi
heureux alors qu'apparemment
matériellement ils sont si pauvres
comment peuvent être triste il plein de
joie et d'enthousiasmé
alors qu'apparemment tout et noirceur
comment peuvent-ils avoir des cérémonies
à toute heure de la vie et de la nuit
avec plein de musique alors que vous
avez les klaxons les plus stressants et
un sur dix ans comment peuvent-ils avoir
des enfants qui m'accueille avec autant
d'enthousiasmé
alors qu'apparemment ils ont seulement
une vieille roue de vélo rouillé et
trois bâtons pour s'amuser et comment
peuvent-ils vivre et se nourrir alors
qu'ils peuvent même pas acheter le
dernier iphone il a fallu que je me
rende à l'évidence il était peut-être
animé par autre chose que la performance
alors scolaire je suis retourné dans les
livres je suis retourné sur les bancs
d'école
et là j'ai découvert pléthore
d'indicateurs il y en a des loufoques
par exemple
l'indicateur mcdo c'est l'indicateur qui
mesure le pouvoir d'achat dans un pays
un mcdo à delhi ne coûte pas le même
prix qu'un mac do en france mais
celui-là je n'aime pas alors j'ai
continué mes recherches et là j'ai
découvert le bnb bonheur national brut
vous avez peut-être entendu parler de ce
pays le bhoutan au nord-est de l'inde
qui utilisent le bnb pour diriger son
pays
c'est un indicateur qui mesure le
bonheur dans son pays
ça repose sur l'économie et le social
sur l'environnement sur la tradition et
sur le pouvoir de style de gouvernance
c'est une monarchie le bhoutan est il il
repousse tous les parasites du bonheur à
tel point qu'au bord de ce pays vous
avez l'un des camps de réfugiés les plus
grands au monde tous les népalais qui
ont été refoulés alors ce pays ne
convient peut-être pas à ce que cet
indicateur ne convient peut-être pas à
tous les pays
j'ai continué mes recherches et là je
suis tombée sur les programmes des
nations unies du développement qui
travaille sur l'idée h l'indicateur du
développement humain
c'est cet indicateur qui repose sur le
pib mais aussi au niveau santé sur
l'espérance de vie et aussi au niveau
éducation sur l'eau taux
d'alphabétisation et le taux de
scolarisation mais en me connectant au
fond de moi même je me disais il manque
encore quelque chose
j'ai envie d'avoir un indicateur avec
encore plus de sens qui me fait encore
plus vibrer pour tenir aussi compte de
l'environnement des inégalités sociales
du travail bénévole pour sa famille pour
ses amis pour toute action car
hâtives et aussi pour l'épanouissement
de soi même pour plus de conscience
confiance humour et amour
alors il a fallu me rendre à l'évidence
cet indicateur n'existait pas j'ai donc
choisi mon propre indicateur le flou
score c'est un indicateur qui vous
permet d'évaluer le votre niveau d'être
dans le courant de la vie c'est cet
indicateur qui repose sur le concept du
flou flow flow3r aussi de la psychologie
positive qui a été très bien décrit par
le psychologue me ali mechiche sensme
ali qui a écrit un livre le flou c'est
ce moment où vous êtes comme dans votre
bulle en pleine concentration en dehors
de l'espace temps complètement aligné
avec vos valeurs vos talents votre
raison d'être
tenez par exemple quand vous êtes au
volant de votre voiture
perdu dans vos pensées tout d'un coup
vous vous réveillez et c'est vous avez
l'impression de haut
déjà 50 km mais je les ai pas vues
passer
et oui à ce moment là vous étiez dans le
flou vous pouvez la voir aussi dans le
sport dans l'art en musique ou bien en
discussion entre deux amis entre deux
passionnés et vous êtes tellement dedans
que vous en oubliez tout ce qui se passe
autour
vous en oubliez de manger dormir de
boire vous êtes pleinement dedans c'est
presque un état méditatif un état de
grâce
c'est aussi ce que les scientifiques
appellent la sérendipité
c'est ce moment où vous faites des
découvertes par hasard
par exemple vous avez l'amérique de
christophe colomb
la palestine depuis fleming ou bien le
velcro de mestral d'un côté vous
découvrez un continent un remède miracle
ou bien un tissu attachant alors ce flou
c'est un état vraiment puissant un état
de grâce
tellement fort que quand vous êtes dans
les moments de doute les moments de peur
car oui changer de d'un 10 d'indicateurs
de vie ça demande de la force sa demande
de la confiance et vous pouvez être
chahuté par votre environnement est
envahi par tous ces doutes par toutes
ces peurs mais le flou est tellement
fort qui va vous permettre de continuer
à aller au delà et pour moi et bien oui
j'ai rencontré ses difficultés ses
doutes et ses peurs en particulier quand
je suis rentré d'inde
j'ai divorcé et le juge a décidé que mes
enfants ma chère mais amour
inconditionnel seraient gardés par leurs
pairs plus de câlins le soir plus de
bisous plus de jeu ensemble plus de rire
plus de mamans au mental avait mon
t-shirt de foot
alors là je le monde s'est effondré et
je me suis reconnecter au flou
et en fait aujourd'hui je peux vous
assurer que la relation que j'ai avec
mes enfants et d'une complicité
incroyable d'un niveau que je ne pensais
même pas possible nous savons à distance
quand nous sommes heureux nous savons
quand nous sommes en difficulté
nous savons quand nous avons besoin de
soutien
alors oui ça vaut le coup d'aller
affronter ses doutes ses peurs ses
difficultés et de se reconnecter à sa
flamme intérieure alors le flou ça se
développe
vous pouvez le développer en allant
davantage dans la nature ou bien en
écoutant davantage votre intuition ou
bien l'innovation frugale mais aussi
votre corps alors je vais vous montrer
je vais prendre un risque devant nu vous
j'ai décidé de me mettre à nu devant
vous j'ai bien dit un nu j'ai pas dis nu
je vais vous faire une pause cherche à
sanaa c'est la pause au roi du yoga pour
moi c'est celle qui symbolise notre
monde aujourd'hui c'est aussi celle qui
développe le follow qui vous aident à
voir plus de concentration de clarté des
décisions de mémoire alors je vous
montre
là je suis en inde je suis de l'autre
côté de la planète
j'ai la tête à l'envers en même temps
pour moi cette position symbolise le
mieux que notre monde marche sur la tête
alors maintenant à vous à vous de sortir
de votre zone de confort
je vous rassure j'ai pas vous demander
tout de suite de mettre la tête au sol
mais je vous propose quand même de vous
lever
de vous étirer et de croiser vos mains
dans le dos et de tendre les bras vers
le bas et vers l'arrière en même temps
rouler les épaules vers l'arrière et
garder la tête droite
qu'est ce qui se passe quand vous faites
ça en roulant les épaules vers l'arrière
par votre corps vous augmentez votre
confiance en vous en même temps vous
ouvrez le chakra du coeur vous vous
ouvrez aux autres vous favorisez le flou
autour de vous maintenant vous aviez
peut-être le petit doigt gauche en bas
alors je vous demande de changer le
croisement des mains et de maître par
exemple le petit doigt gauche en bas et
de nouveau tendez les bras vers le bas
et vers l'arrière en continuant à rouler
les épaules vers l'arrière et là qu'est
ce que vous avez fait et bien en
changement ce croisement des doigts vous
avez fait une action inhabituelle
vous avez créé des nouvelles connexions
dans votre cerveau et vous avez
développé ses capacités adaptatives et
de créativité
vous pouvez vous rasseoir
et je vais vous demander encore un peu
de concentration et de continuer à
développer le flou en vous
j'ai ramené ce bol tibétain de là bas
c'est un bol qui vibre qui génère une
vibration d'amour je vous propose de
mettre vos deux pieds au sol de garder
la colonne vertébrale droite vous pouvez
garder soit les yeux ouverts soit les
fermer et relâchez votre feront relâche
et vosges ou relâchés vos épaules
relâchez votre torse ressentez vos
fesses sur la chaise relâche et vos
jambes et jusqu'aux pieds
et doucement vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
là certains d'entre vous sont dans le
flou sur cet indicateur de flou score
vous êtes à 10 sur 10 vous êtes ouvert
aux autres vous êtes comme sur une même
longueur d'onde est dans cette dynamique
là pour vous ou avec votre équipe vous
pouvez réaliser les projets les plus
fous transporter les montagnes vous vous
êtes ouvert au monde
vous êtes dans le monde vous êtes le
monde
alors maintenant quel monde avez vous
envie de voir qu'est ce qui vous anime
au plus profond de vous quelle est la
flamme que vous avez envie de réveiller
qu'elle est l'indicateur de vie que vous
avez envie de choisir
alors maintenant quels indicateurs de
vie avez vous envie de choisir
merci
[Applaudissements]